vadim yonatan is jewish
and he supports the afd when he was 19
he left ukraine and the discrimination
he felt there as a jew
and came to germany now he fears
anti-semitism here
there are lots of problems in germany
which weren't there before
and are only being addressed by the afd
i'm talking about the clear
anti-semitism you can see in the quran
and because there are so many migrants
from the region that has this religion
it's clear that we're going to see more
and more anti-semitism in germany
it might seem paradoxical for jewish
people to join the afd
but they have and on sunday they're
setting up a formal group in the party
their spokesman is dimitri schultz he's
a jew from the former soviet union
and he sees the afd as the only party
fighting muslim anti-semitism
unfortunately many germans have no sense
of homeland
and this homeland is in danger
the ellensburg polling institute says
anti-semitism is much more prevalent in
the afd than in other parties
and the afd leadership has faced
repeated criticism for playing down the
crimes of the nazis
hitler and the nazis are no more than a
speck of bird poop in more than a
thousand years of successful german
history
sergei lagodinsky is a leading member of
berlin's jewish community
and as far as he's concerned jews
joining the afd is a bad joke
but he says the party is resonating with
some jewish groups
we shouldn't forget that about 90 of
jewish people
in germany are also of eastern european
origin will mostly come from the soviet
union
and bring the whole baggage of um
stereotypes and and a kind of a
non-liberal understanding of democracy
and also there are people who are german
speakers
speaking who are right wing and who are
trying to use this and instrumentalize
this feeling and this is what we're
seeing
the jews in the afg group would get
short shrift at the maseltov israeli
restaurant in berlin
the jewish owner kostapinsky sees the
group as no more than a tactic to divert
attention
from afd anti-semitism
it is irreconcilable jews cannot be
involved in a party which is clearly
associated with anti-semitic motivations
and anti-semitic people
it doesn't make sense to trust people
like that
costa pinsky believes the afd is clearly
anti-semitic and a group of jews in the
party
won't change that